In this presentation, we will start to have some experience
In solving the root equations or equations containing
Square root or higher roots
Also we will try to understand
An important phenomenon that will crystallize during the solution of equations
Let me clarify what I'm talking about
Suppose I have the following equation: square root of x =
2 (x-6)
Now, one of the things you will see when you solve
Such radical equations are that we will have to isolate at least one
From the roots
In this equation we have one root
When we isolate one of the roots in one end of the
The equation, it looks like this, I have here
The square root of the x is isolated at the left end, then we do
Quadrature the two ends of the equation
Let's if we cross the two sides of the equation
I will write it again
I will solve them leisurely
I will quadruple this and will equal (2x
- 6) ^ 2
The squaring process is good
If this is equal to this, then this phrase is equal
That box
So continue
When we take the square root of x we ​​square it
The output will be x
We get x = - the square of this statement = 2x) ^ 2)
Ie 4x ^ 2
This phrase is originally 2x
4x ^ 2, and multiply these two values, so the output
-12x
When we quadrature it becomes -24x
Then-^ 2 = 36
If you find that moving from these to these is difficult, maybe
You have to check out Multiprogram statements, or
Multiply equations, or special cases
In which we multiply the binomial equations
But in general, this phrase square, are the same ones
Then we have -2x these two products
The output of these two amounts is -12x
If 2 × 24x and all this amount square
If this is the equation
As simple as possible, and see what happens if we targe x
From both ends of the equation
If we subtract x from both ends of the equation
The left side will be 0 and the right side
It will be 4x ^ 2 - 25x + 36
If the root equation has been simplified to become just
Normal quadratic equation
We will not analyze it to its causes
Or we are gathering and not all that, let 's just deal with
Quadratic formula
The quadratic formula states that these solutions are
x can equal -b
-25
The minus-25 equals a positive 25 + or -
Square root of 25 ^ 2
25 ^ 2 = 625, -4 × a = 4 × c
= 26, and all this divided by 2 x 4, which is divided by 8
Let us use the calculator until we find
The output of this
I'll pull out the calculator
We say that 625 - - to see, these
Become 16 × 36
16 x 36 = 49
this is good
It's a full box
We know that the square root of 49
Is 7
So let me get back to the issue
If this simplifies to 49
If x = 25 + or - the square root of
It is 7, all divided by 8
These are the two solutions. If we add 7, we get x =
25 + 7 = 32, 32/8 = 4
The other solution, let me do it
In a different color
x = 25 - 7, and is equal to 18/8
18 8 8 = 2, and the rest 2, if the output of this is
2 2/8 or 2 1/4 or 2.25
Now I will show you
Interesting phenomenon
And perhaps will stop when I explain to whom
Puzzle, I will tell you the reason
The appearance of this puzzle
Let's examine the success of solutions
Let's try if x = 4
If x = 4 succeeds we get the square root of 4
And is equal to 2, 4 × 6
The square root for 4 is 2
Positive 2 = 2 × 4, equal to 8, - 6
Equal
That's true
If successful 4
Now, let's try 2.25
According to this, we take the square root
L 2.2 - I will
Maximize the root signal slightly
The square root of 2.25 equals 2 ×
2.25-6
Now, maybe you can do this mentally
You may know that the square root of 225 is 15
Hence, you can be able to find
The square root of 2.25 is 1.5
Let me use the calculator to prove this to you
We take the square root for 2.25
It's 1.5
The square root is 1.5
The other square root is -1.5
If 1.5
.
Hence, accordingly, this will be equal to 2
Ø 2.25 = 4.5, - 6
Now, is that true?
This tells us that 1.5 = -1.5
this is not true
2.5 did not succeed to solve this root equation
This is what we call the extraordinary solution
If 2.25 is considered an exceptional solution
Now, the puzzle is: Why did we get the answer 2.25?
We seem to have done the right things
We got a quadratic equation in addition to 2.25
We have a tip here
When we make up 2.25 we get 1.5
= -1.5
If there is something here, something we did and gave us this
The solution does not succeed when you use it
I will give you another hint
Let's try it at this point
If we look carefully at this step, we will see that both
Both solutions are already valid
You can try it if you want
In fact, try it on your own
Replace 2.25 instead of x here
And you'll see that will work
And replace with 4 instead of x and you will see that both are fit
If both are considered valid solutions to this equation
Both are good solutions to this equation
If something happens while we are squaring the equation, make it
slightly different
There is something in this equation a little different
For that equation
The answer is that we have two ways to think about them
To return from this equation to that, and take
Sqrt
But to be more precise, I am taking
Square root for both parties
Now, the negative square root can also be taken
Note, this is just the extraction of the square root
Let's move from here - let me be clearer
This phrase, I have already proved that both
Equations, and both the right and extraordinary solution
To this root equation
Saleh for the equation
Only the good solution achieves the equation
So let me write the equation and both of them will achieve the equation
Because it is already an interesting puzzle
I think this will give you a little difference
It will tell you what will happen when we take
The root of these values
And why when we cross both sides
We can think of it, to a certain extent, as a loss or a compilation
Some information
Now, these can be written as follows: x =
(2x-6) ^ 2
This is one of the valid solutions for this
The equation
But here we have a logical explanation
For this equation
It can be x = -1
× (2x - 6) ^ 2
Why are these interpretations considered equal?
Because when we square -1, it will disappear
They are equal terms
To write this in another way,
Is x = -
We hit -1 × that
We get -2x + 6 or (6-2x) ^ 2
These are two ways to write the equation
Now, when you look at the square root or when - think
There are two ways to think about it
When we squirt it, assume that this is
The only explanation, but we got another explanation
If we find two answers to these, but the 4 achieved
The equation
I hope you have absorbed what I say because all I do
Is that I take - you can imagine the square root positive
It will not be taken as negative square root
Because when we take the square root of both sides even
We get here, we've just taken root
To put it another way - let me rewrite
The original equation
Let me rewrite the original equation
We have a square root of x = 2x - 6
We found 4 to be a solution to the equation
And 2.25 is not a solution
2.25 is not considered a solution if we say that both
The square roots of x = 2x - 6
Try it now and it will be for 2.25
correct answer
If we take the negative square root for 2.25, it is
2 x 2.25, and equal to 4.5 - 6
Ie -1.5
That's true
The positive image is x = 4
That's why we got two answers
And if we want to squat this - maybe this method is even simpler
Remember this
If you quadruple this, you will get this equation
So both solutions are valid
Now, maybe you have found this
A little annoying
But it is not my intention to bother you
The simplest thing you can think of when you are solving
Radical equations is, to isolate the roots, and to lay down the phrases, then
Please find the solution
You will probably get more than one answer
It must fill the deficit of answers
The answers that did not work are called extraordinary solutions
But most of the explanation in this lesson was about why
The advent of these extraordinary solutions
I hope that I gave you the intuition that the equation
Equals the square root of x
The exceptional solution would be valid if we took +
Or - square root of x, not the root only